When "Jeopardy" co-hosts Mayim Bialik
and Ken Jennings were tapped to take
over for the late Alex Trebek, some longtime
viewers were none too pleased — and these
offensive comments from both co-hosts
didn't exactly win them any fans.
Mayim Bialik has been a fixture on television for
as far back as many viewers can remember. Back
in the '90s, she starred in the titular role
of Blossom Russo in the NBC sitcom "Blossom"
before pivoting to voice work on cartoons like
"Johnny Bravo," "Recess," and "Kim Possible."
Today, however, she's better known for her
long-running role as Amy Farrah Fowler on
"The Big Bang Theory," which she played
beginning in Season 3 of the hit sitcom.
More recently, viewers will recognize her from
another sitcom, "Call Me Kat," and as one of
two recurring hosts on "Jeopardy" following
the passing of longtime host Alex Trebek.
Unfortunately, despite her background in
science and academics, Bialik isn't always
viewed as a popular choice for the hosting gig
on "Jeopardy." This is because of controversial
comments that she made in a New York Times
op-ed that many viewed as victim-blaming,
as well as a host of other problematic
statements that she's made regarding
vaccines and her partnership with the
controversial neurological supplement Neuriva.
In response to the Harvey
Weinstein scandal, Bialik wrote:
"I still make choices every day as a 41-year-old
actress that I think of as self-protecting and
wise. I have decided that my sexual self is
best reserved for private situations with
those I am most intimate with. I dress modestly.
I don't act flirtatiously with men as a policy."
It is the last part of that statement
that drew the most ire for Bialik,
as many read it as shaming women or victim
blaming. Though she was clear throughout that
she sees herself as a feminist and wishes
that the world were different for women
and girls in the entertainment industry, the
blowback was swift from opponents of her piece.
Actor Gabrielle Union tweeted that, when she
had been sexually assaulted while working at
a Payless, she "had on a long tunic & leggings."
She added, "so miss me w/ 'dress modestly' s---."
Elsewhere, Bialik served as
the public face for Neuriva,
a supplement that Psychology Today called "snake
oil." This made some question her intentions,
as many took it as Bialik using her celebrity to
cash in without properly vetting the product that
she was selling on CBS between episodes
of "Jeopardy" and "The Big Bang Theory."
This isn't all when it comes to the criticism
that Bialik has received in terms of her takes
on medical matters. Despite being a scientist
herself, the actor said previously that she
did not vaccinate her children. Again,
she walked this back somewhat by getting
the flu shot and COVID-19 vaccine later on,
but for many, the damage was already done.
"This year, I'm going to do something
I literally haven't done in 30 years.
I'm gonna get a vaccine."
This has been compounded by her promotion
of Attachment Parenting in her book,
"Beyond the Sling: A Real-Life
Guide to Raising Confident,
Loving Children the Attachment Parenting
Way." This is because Attachment Parenting,
or AP, is a belief system that is often seen as
going hand-in-hand with anti-vaccine beliefs.
While some fans might point to fellow "Jeopardy"
host Ken Jennings as the easy alternative to
Bialik in the wake of these issues, Jennings also
has a history of making problematic statements.
In particular, the host and longtime "Jeopardy"
contestant tweeted out an ableist post on Twitter,
writing that there's, quote, "Nothing
sadder than a hot person in a wheelchair."
Jennings has also been accused of sexism and
favoritism. In an episode of "Jeopardy" that
aired on September 14, 2022, Jennings
allowed a contestant to amend his answer
after he said "Constant" instead of
"Constable," a factor that many fans
found to be a double standard after he ruled
an answer incorrect from a previous female
contestant because she mispronounced
the answer, despite being correct.
"Oh s—!!"
Sadly, this seems to show that neither of Alex
Trebek's replacements may be the right person
for the job, especially when you consider
the high bar that was set by the host's
squeaky-clean background and generally
beloved disposition. As it turns out,
some fans think both co-hosts are, well …
"They're both losers."